c'est bien modestement bien humblement
que je remplacerais si tenté qu'il soit
remplaçable président bizet sur un sujet
très grave
notre commission a adopté le 18 décembre
dernier la proposition de renault de
résolution européenne sur l'appui
européen un mécanismes de justice
transitionnelle en irak déposée par
notre collègue bruno retailleau et 80
membres du groupe sénatorial de
réflexion de vigilance et de solidarité
avec les chrétiens les minorités au
moyen-orient et les kurdes
le rapport de la commission des affaires
étrangères va dans le même sens la
défaite militaire de dèche pas encore
définitif d'ailleurs ne doit pas
aujourd'hui faire oublier le sort
dramatique des communautés chrétiennes
et des minorités en irak de 860 milles
en 2014 le nombre de chrétiens est passé
à moins de 400 mille aujourd'hui 125
mille chrétiens auraient quitté l'irak
pour la seule année 2014
le sort des fidèles des religions
syncrétique pré islamique n'est guère
plus enviable
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
préconise la mise en place en irak avec
l'appui de l'union européenne d'un
mécanisme de justice transitionnelle à
même de faciliter la réconciliation
entre les communautés qui composent ce
pays
l'union européenne s'est engagée à de
multiples reprises depuis 2003 pour la
reconstruction en irak notamment au plan
financier
c'est dans ce contexte que la
proposition de résolution européenne
propose le fléchage d'une partie des
financements européens vers un mécanisme
de justice transitionnelle permettant de
qualifier et juger les crimes commis par
des shows sur le territoire irakien
le texte demande en premier lieu que ce
dispositif est une dimension
internationale
la proposition de résolution européenne
met judicieusement en avant l'exemple
des chambres extraordinaires auprès des
tribunaux cambodgiens composée de
magistrats internationaux et cambodgiens
créée afin de traduire en justice les
responsables des crimes commis par les
khmers rouges
l'union européenne financent pour partie
leur activité ce dispositif pourrait
être dupliquée à l'échelle irakienne
l'ajout d'une dimension internationale
doit constituer en tout état de cause
une des conditions du soutien européen
la proposition de résolution européenne
insiste également sur le travail de
formation des enquêteurs et des juges
l'union européenne pourrait renforcer le
mandat de l'actuelle mission le huard m
irak et contribuer à la formation des
forces de sécurité irakiennes aux
enquêtes sur les crimes de guerre et les
crimes contre l'humanité une telle
option faciliterait indéniablement la
coopération avec l'équipe d'enquêteurs
des nations unies chargée de recueillir
des preuves en irak qui va commencer ses
travaux dans les prochaines semaines la
proposition appelle en outre à la mise
en place d'une mission européenne
destinée à former le personnel
judiciaire en le sensibilisant
particulièrement aux spécificités des
instructions visant crimes de guerre ou
crimes contre l'humanité une telle
mission viendrait compléter tout à la
fois le travail des enquêteurs et celui
des chambres mixtes que je viens
d'évoquer
l'union européenne dispose d'une
expertise en la matière de par le monde
il faut s'appuyer dessus je rappellerai
pour conclure que l'union européenne est
souvent là pour mettre fin au conflit
je pense toutes proportions gardées à
son rôle essentiel dans l'accord du
vendredi saint qui a fait cesser la
guerre civile en ulster en irak
elle peut te vrai à la réconciliation
des différentes communautés
c'est pourquoi la commission des
affaires européennes émet un avis
favorable sur ce texte
je vous remercie